La volta al món a peu, dia 264, estic a la parada de taxis del poble i m'han vingut tots els taxistes a dir
Duxambe, Duxambe, que jo no, no, no, Duxambe no, però sí, però sí que vull el taxi.
El que no saben és que només necessito que em condueixin 3 quilòmetres fins a l'intersecció.
Quina intersecció, Enric? De què m'estàs parlant?
Bueno, els que no vau veure el vídeo d'ahir, doncs no us ho explicaré.
Anem a veure el vídeo d'ahir i ja està.
Total, ara els diré que només vull que em condueixin 3 quilòmetres, a veure si no m'envien a Pastafang.
Són 6 minuts de trajecte, he intentat negociar el preu, però no em baixen de 30 soms, que són 3 euros.
Bueno, què hi farem? A la capital això costa res, menys d'un euro.
3 euros, ja està.
Molt bé, és que em fa pal pujar caminant, em fa palíssim perquè és pujada i perquè, home,
són 3 quilòmetres de gratis que no tinc.
A veure què n'has de fer. Let's go!
D'acord, doncs en aquesta intersecció és on he retallat el tract d'Estrava d'ahir.
Donem el play i a caminar cap allà.
Ja porto 5 quilòmetres i mig caminats per aquesta carretera, tot pujada.
Ara aquí hi ha un market on m'aprovisionaré d'aigua perquè no sé quan serà el següent market.
I com veieu la carretera està super bé, es nota que és nova, eh?
Estàndards, anava a dir europeus, no, estàndards turcs,
i dic, ostres, que poc trànsit, tu, que bé que s'està aquí, que bé que es va,
que pocs camions, no hi ha cap camió.
Wait, espera, no hi ha cap camió.
Com pot ser que no hi hagi cap camió?
M'estic espantant, eh?
M'estic espantant que no m'hagi tornat a equivocar de camí.
Per si aquesta carretera no la posa algú al marx, potser.
Bueno, vaig a preguntar al minimàrquing aquest a veure si puc anar, o em vull anar per aquí,
o està tallat, o a saber què.
No ho sé, ostres, no podem, eh?
He anat a l'home del market, que no parla anglès,
i l'he anat dient als pobles, i li pregunto, open, open,
l'he dit tunnel, tritunnel, i li diu, sí, sí, sí, tritunnel.
He dit al traductor, he dit open, i li he preguntat al traductor,
per què no hi ha camions?
S'ha rigut, i diu, ja.
Li he posat amb el traductor, suspicious, sospitós.
Li he dit, sí, sí, open, open, open.
Llavors després m'ha preguntat, on està el següent supermercat, a quina distància?
Li he dit, més o menys, 10, 20, li poso la calculadora, quilòmetre, quilòmetre.
I m'agafa la calculadora i em posa 350.
És a dir, que no ens hem entès, perquè evidentment el següent supermercat no està a 350 quilòmetres.
Bueno.
Que sigui el que Déu vulgui, tu sempre puc fer autostop si em moro de set o si no hi ha carretera.
M'he comprat unes peres, a un que has de venir aquí a la carretera.
Oh, sucoses, oh, boníssimes, boníssimes.
Bueno, estem als 1.900 metres sobre el nivell del mar,
i aquí darrere, com podeu veure, tenim el primer túnel.
La diferència entre aquest túnel i el túnel de la mort, espero que siguin moltes,
però la principal és que aquest té una alternativa.
L'alternativa, que la veieu aquí en imatges, doncs dona molta volta.
I no l'agafaré.
Agafaré el túnel, sí, agafaré el túnel perquè, bueno, que pites!
El túnel té molta millor pinta, encara no he entrat, encara no ho sé,
però veig que, per exemple, està molt millor il·luminat.
I, per mi, el més important no és si està il·luminat, si hi ha gasos, si no hi ha gasos.
El principal problema és que no hi ha trànsit.
Comparat amb el túnel de la mort, en aquest túnel, li direm el túnel de la vida.
No hi ha... És que aquí passa un cotxe cada 30 segons.
El túnel de la mort era una constant de camions, pa, pa, era brutal, era brutal.
I bueno, es veu més modern, es veu més modern.
Són 1,6 quilòmetres, ho veiem aquí, que ho posa.
Túnel original.
Orellona.
Let's go!
Entrar en el túnel sense el mirar reflectant, sense frontal i sense mascareta. Yolo!
Bueno, per començar ja veig ventiladors.
És a dir, hi ha circulació d'aire i es nota l'ambient.
És a dir, no...
Bueno, suposo perquè el fet que no hi hagi camions és el més important, eh?
Però, sobretot, perquè hi ha circulació d'aigua, d'aire, la il·luminació és molt bona.
I, per exemple, hi ha circulació d'aigua, d'aire, la il·luminació és molt bona.
Podria caminar per aquí, però no ho faré perquè ja et dic, no cal.
Bueno, doncs res, ens adentrem, ens adentrem.
Hi ha un, bueno, no diria voral, però bueno, sí, petit voral.
I pim-pam, sí, sí, està millor aquí que fora.
I túnel tot, tu.
Clar, no dóna el sol.
Que em posin més túnels, tu, tot el dia.
Ostres, tu, ja es veu la llum al final del túnel.
Quina llàstima, amb el que heu estat, que ho tinc.
No és broma, eh?
Dels millors estones de caminar de l'última setmana.
Perquè he estat caminant amb calor, sol,
que pica i no para, no dóna treva.
Mira, aquí està bé.
Bueno, he de dir que els ventiladors aquests no funcionen.
Estan tancats, estan apagats.
N'hi ha un, mira, ja n'hi ha un que funciona.
Sí, bueno, doncs no sé.
Em pregunto qui deu haver construït aquesta autopista,
aquesta carretera, aquests túnels.
No té pinta que hagin sigut els Tajiks, eh?
Digueu-me...
Prejudiciós?
No sé si existeix aquesta paraula, però això està massa ben fet.
Sortida del túnel.
Just ara passen els primers dos camions del dia.
El d'abans i aquest d'ara d'aquí.
Molt bé, tu.
Doncs res, tornem al sol i l'abrasió.
Encara queden dos túnels més.
Crec que avui un i demà un altre.
Encara no estem a la Pamir Profunda,
perquè encara hi ha supermercats que dos per tres aquí.
Encara no estem a la Pamir Profunda, perquè encara hi ha supermercats que dos per tres aquí.
Encara que tinguem
Les dues i quart.
22 quilòmetres gairebé
força bé
tenint en compte que he començat a les 9 a caminar
i ja sabem qui fa
aquesta carretera
o pel que sembla han fet els xinesos
hi ha una planta formigonera
o no sé què és això
i altres xines, suposo que són els xinesos
segon túnel, túnel de
Baghdad
raro perquè Baghdad era un poble que vam passar
fa 4 o 5 dies
1.700 metres, una mica més llarg que l'altre
millor
vaja, potser no s'aprecia però
ara de cop i volta
s'ha fet de nit
la llum del túnel s'ha anat
hauria de trobar el frontal
però em fa bastanta mandra
no, el que faré serà
pareu
com queden 500 metres o menys
el que faré serà
il·luminar-me amb el flash
del mòbil perquè és que ara trobar la motxilla
trobar el frontal fa mandra
si creieu que jo estic loco
m'acabo de trobar uns nens
amb dos burros
caminant per aquí per les plataformes aquestes
que el pobre burro s'entrebancava
doncs, vegem-ho a l'altre punt
com s'ac Mormont
s'ha fet de nit
doncs sí
hòstia, que un cri dizzy
l'alcaldessa m'ha logut trucar
per آqu
moltes gràcies, Lluís
a de sabotaged of einmal
Les 5 i 18, estic cansat, estic cansat, estic cansat de caminar i cansat de tanta calor, estic cansat de tanta calor.
Bé, us he dit que el tercer túnel era demà, doncs no, és avui, no he calculat bé.
Túnel d'Isticlol, és el més llarg de tots, dos quilòmetres i mig.
Perfecte, tu, estarem fresquets una estona.
Doncs, dos defectes que té aquest túnel, és tota empujada, no és culpa seva suposo, però no està il·luminat, tu, res, zero il·luminació, tu, quin desastre.
He arribat a un poble on no hi ha massa res, però aquí hi ha un casoplón que flipes i una persona que estava regant, no sé si és el jardiner o què,
m'ha dit, vine, vine, vine, vine, i jo que és tard, estic cansat, tinc set i tinc gana, doncs a veure si no n'hi ha alguna.
Estava parlant aquí amb l'home de la casa, que m'ha portat te, pa, mel, tot molt bo.
Bé, parlant, a veure, parlant, jo quan dic parlar ja m'enteneu.
I ara està allà, no l'enfoco, però està dintre casa, amb les finestres al veig, i m'ha dit, espera un moment, i s'ha anat a resar.
I porta dos, tres minuts resant.
Encara dura, encara dura.
Jocs culturals, però bueno, el lloc és increïble.
M'han convidat a dormir aquí, i encara que era a les sis i mitja quan m'ho han dit, he dit que sí, perquè avui estic més cansat de l'habitual, tu, em quedo.
Ha acabat de resar, però no ha tornat.
Bueno, tampoc hi havia massa conversa.
Ah, hi ha una abella per aquí.
Bueno, m'han portat una sopa, tu, que bé, tu.
Que bé, porta un tros, un parell de trossos de vedella i tot, mireu.
No, Enric, no hauries de menjar coses que portin aigua, perquè no sé què.
Va, home, tio, per favor.
Si no, no menjaria res.
Això suposo que haurà embullit, no?
Haurà eliminat els bacteris, dic jo, no sé.
Bueno, moltes coses a explicar.
A veure, per començar, us explico el lloc on dormiré, que és aquesta espècie de quadrat, aquí, cobert, que hi ha aquí fora al jardí.
I com podeu escoltar, suposo que ho escolteu, està al costat de la carretera.
I quan pugen els cotxes, sobretot quan pugen, perquè és una pujada, doncs, fa bastant soroll el motor.
M'han ofert dormir a dintre, eh, però he dit que fora, perquè, bueno, he pensat que tocaria més l'aire, estaria més fresquet.
I, a més, demà al matí, si em vull llevar d'hora, si em vull llevar d'hora, bueno, doncs no em molestaré, no?
I, a més, jo crec que aquí tinc més intimitat.
Però, bueno, sé que és veritat que espero que deixin de passar cotxes, perquè fa bastant de soroll.
Què més? A veure.
És que...
Aquest home, Ismail, es deia? No, no me'n recordo. Són difícils els noms tàgics, eh?
Doncs, bueno, encara m'ha ofert més menjar.
Jo, quan ja està ple, em porta un plat.
I amb patates, carn i una mica de tomàquet amb ceba.
L'he menjat una mica, molt bo, però, clar, ja no podia més.
Crec que avui és la generositat màxima que he rebut a la volta del món a peu.
Crec que és aquest home, eh? O sigui, increïble.
Després d'això...
M'ensenya els lavabos i les dutxes.
Dutxa i lavabo tajic.
O sigui, un forat, ben acondicionat, eh? Però un forat.
I després la dutxa, doncs, com ahir, no?
Una d'això que rejaven i tu tires per sobre, no?
I jo, bueno, vale, perfecte. Perfecte, gràcies, gràcies.
I diu, no, no, espera, espera.
Mentre dintre casa, em baixa per unes escales...
I jo, a veure on em porta aquest senyor.
Llàstima no haver-ho pogut gravar, eh?
I m'obre una porta i hi ha una dutxa.
Una dutxa. Dutxa. Una dutxa.
Un dutxa occidental i un retrete.
I un retrete. I dic, maixala.
Això dic jo. Ho he pensat.
I sí, sí, m'he dutxat allà, amb xampú, tot.
Tovallola.
O sigui, aquest tio...
Increïble. O sigui...
Rahmat. Moltíssimes, moltíssimes, moltíssimes gràcies.
Espectacular, espectacular.
L'hospitalitat i tot plegat.
Ara bé.
No, ara bé no.
Però m'agradaria dir que aquest home és molt religiós.
S'ha parat dues vegades a resar mentre estava jo aquí.
I els seus fills també estaven resant.
I portava el barret tègic, que no sé quin nom té,
que és així com una gorra, però sense la visera, no?
Més o menys.
I a la gorra aquesta portava un cubicle negre,
que és el...
el cubicle aquest, que no sé com es diu, que hi ha a la Meca.
O sigui, aquest home era molt religiós.
Això no està ben vist aquí, a Tajikistán.
Ja en parlarem d'això, avui no, però ja en parlarem que el govern de Tajikistán no promou això.
Promou el contrari.
Però bueno, ja en parlarem un altre dia.
I un altre detall és que no he vist cap dona.
I són, perquè ja les he escoltat.
Però hi ha una altra porta per allà, per al jardí.
Una part com més privada, suposo.
I...
I no sé si és casualitat o no, però...
En aquest cas jo crec que no és casualitat, eh?
Jo crec que està fet a propòsit perquè no hi hagi aquesta conjunció
entre visitant masculí i dona de la casa femenina.
Però bueno, no ho sé, no ho sé.
En qualsevol cas, em crec aquest home molt amable.
Avui 36 quilòmetres, crec.
M'he parlat amb tres persones, que és l'home aquest i els seus dos fills.
Bueno, i el jardiner, perquè jo diria que és un jardiner.
Aquest home jo crec que té pasta, eh?
Final, quatre persones.
I què més?
Cafè, escap, refrescos...
Un.
Refrescos, un.
I no m'he gastat res.
M'he gastat dos euros, crec.
Amb aigües.
Perquè la compra al supermercat, petita compra.
Ja l'havia fet ahir.
No, posa-li tres.
Posa-li tres euros.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Un dia...
Un dia, això sí, avorrit.
O sigui, aquesta part final ha sigut espectacular, però la resta del dia ha sigut molt avorrit.
Caminant per la carretera aquesta, sí, amb muntanyes, sí, el paisatge no està malament,
però avorrit de la calor i avorrit de tot el dia carretera i sense poca cosa.
Avui per vosaltres és divendres, per mi és dijous.
I demà per vosaltres és dissabte.
Demà no hi ha vídeo.
Jo demà no gravo.
I demà no teniu vídeo.
Perquè és dissabte, que ja us vaig dir que els dissabtes, doncs, a vegades faria festa.
I perquè jo crec que demà serà igual que avui.
Sense túnels, però igual que avui.
Caminar, caminar, caminar, pum, pum, pum.
Avui també he d'explicar més coses.
Ja ho explicaré el proper dia, eh?
Però...
La presa que ens vam trobar ahir, eh?
Buf, lo que he après...
Sí, sí, sí.
Això és un tema, eh?
Un tema interessant.
Vinga.
Bona nit.